Mike Brown who was laid to rest on
August 25th did many things teens do a
little drinking getting high he might
have done some shoplifting but unlike
most teens he was shot six times and
killed by a police officer in a profile
of his life the new york times described
him as quote no angel a phrase that got
twitter fired up with the hashtags I
deserved it and no angel too many the
times is take on brown sounded like
blaming the victim and specifically a
victim who is black olivia cole tweeted
york times i shop lifted as a team got
in fights kicked out of school but being
white if a cop shot me no one would say
hashtag I deserved it Jordan McSwain
says I'm white cheated in school kicked
out of college caught shoplifting had
drug phases New York Times won't say I
deserved it if I get murdered sincerely
kemah pointed out never forget drugs
alcoholic see students hashtag no angel
dandy Lawrence take in case I'm murdered
by a cop New York Times should know I
take an obscene amount of napkins when I
go to fast food places hashtag I
deserved it in the same no angel
paragraph The Times profile also said
Brown at take into rapping in recent
months and wrote vulgar lyrics to which
jared allen tweeted hey new york times
before receiving my computer engineering
degree i listened to rap and cuss like a
sailor the author of the profile Jon
illegal says the no angel line was a
mistake and that he disagreed with
editors about how to mention Browns
interest in rap elegon has been covering
Brown's death and protests in Ferguson
and as an african-american man says he
too is experienced racial profiling but
it was especially stinging considering
how the Times ran a profile alongside of
Browns of the officer who killed him and
the picture was somewhat rosier New York
Times says Mike Brown was no angel
Darren Wilson well-mannered soft-spoken
so a teenager had a turbulent life but
he was also the victim of a terrible
death wasn't there a better way to
describe Michael Brown on the day
funeral
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook